نذهب الى هذه الفقره من انتشار الموضه
السريعه الى قبول ملابس الشارع كمنتج عالي
الجوده والتحول نحو الاستدامه وعوده ظهور
متاجر المنتجات القديمه والتوفير صناعه
الازياء شهدت ايضا تحولا جذريا في العشرين
عاما الماضيه مفهوم الموضه السريعه التي
اشتهرت من قبل متاجر مثل اتش ان ام وزاره
هو المثال الاكثر وضوحا للتغيرات في هذه
الصناعه واصبحت طريقه شائعه للحصول على
ملابس باسعار معقوله وبشكل متكرر كما ان
قبول ازياء الشارع كازياء راقيه وفاخره
جعل الناس الان يرتدون انماطا مستوحاه من
ازياء الشارع وظهرت الملابس الصديقه
للبيئه والمواد تدويرها مع الادراك
الكثيرين لتاثير قطاع الازياء الكبير على
البيئه فيما يتجه البعض الى متاجر التوفير
والمتاجر العتيقه كبديل للشراء ملابس
جديده
ولعقود طويله اتجه العالم غربا فيما يتعلق
بالموضه وكان يكفي ان تحمل اي قطعه ملصقه
لبيت ازياء فرنسي او ايطالي او انجليزي
واخيرا امريكي بعد ان اقتحمت نيويورك قلاع
الموضه العالميه الان تغيرت خريطه الموضه
كثيرا بسبب ظاهره اقبال اسيا على شراء
كبرى بيوت الازياء فيما يعرف بتعديل
الملصقات